hey what is up guys mkbhd here and as
promised this is a first look and
impressions of the all-new iphone 10 r
and i have a sneaky feeling this is
gonna be the way to go for a lot of
people this year so in case you missed
it apple just announced three new
iphones iphone 10s
iphone 10s max and iphone 10 r my full
video detailing the 10s and 10x max is
live it's linked below those are the
more familiar phones that we are
expecting but a little bit of a curious
new look that's different
is this r so iphone 10r has the same a12
bionic chip as the other two phones the
same ram the same new upgraded internal
specs the same face id the same notch
the same ios 12 the same speakers the
same lightning
so
what's different what makes it the r
also i don't really know what the r
stands for there could be a couple
things but there's a couple things that
make this phone the r first off it's an
lcd display instead of the oled in the
other two phones not a huge deal on the
surface as apple generally makes pretty
good lcds but it's also worth noting
it's a lower resolution as well
1792
by 828 so a little bit above 720p
on a 6.1 inch display so it's not going
to be the sharpest screen in the world
it's still over 300 pixels per inch but
you can't even watch 1080p hd videos on
the screen which is a bit of a bummer so
definitely keep that in mind and then
the other difference with the display is
the bezels all the way around are just
slightly thicker and this has to do with
the fact that you can bend an lcd
display like you can with an oled and
those other iphones have a display going
right up to basically the edge to the
corner because you can tuck the drivers
in the edge and the oled right up to the
corners that's what they did with the
iphone 10. with iphone 10 r and this lcd
you have what they're calling a liquid
retina display which basically means
they tried their best but you can't
quite get to touching the edge with this
kind of screen so you'll notice every
10r has a slightly thicker bezel a
little bit of a chin it's noticeable for
me someone who's been using an iphone 10
for a while but it's actually still way
better obviously than the huge forehead
and chin we had on iphone 8. the screen
is still true tone it still has touch to
wake but it's now lacking 3d touch so no
force pressing things anymore on iphone
10r
but to be honest they kind of built
around that with a long press in areas
where 3d touch might be missed like the
control center
and truthfully i won't really miss it i
barely use 3d touch ever anyway but now
you know another major difference iphone
10r has a single camera as you can see
instead of the dual camera setup so this
single camera is the same as the primary
one on the 10s it's the newest 12
megapixel camera with optical image
stabilization an f 1.8 aperture new
image processing all that and it still
has actually that software enabled
portrait mode as well including the
adjustment of the bokeh effect and
everything so you're really not missing
out on much of anything in the camera
department at all just literally the
telephoto lens which is impressive
and then other minor things the iphone
10r is ip67 rated not ip68
but the real difference the head turner
that you've definitely noticed by now is
all these new colors iphone 10r comes in
six new colors red
blue
coral
yellow
white and black and i'm gonna you know
what i'm gonna go through each one of
these with like a sort of a mini review
because that's what we do here right
okay so let's start with the coral it's
a it's this sort of a peachy pastel
color maybe more of a salmon depending
on how the light hits it and then all
these iphone 10rs have aluminum frames
instead of stainless steel so they do
color the frames too and this salmon has
a sort of like this pale orange frame to
it it's all right i'm going to go 6 out
of 10. white is sort of like your de
facto standard so it actually is
brighter and actually white compared to
the silver that we have on the iphone 10
so it's actually different and then the
sides are still silver but they're also
pretty bright not really a whole ton of
contrast on this phone since everything
is so bright here but hey if you like to
keep it clean this is the clean look i'm
going to go 6.5 out of 10. then there's
the blue this is nice this is this is
like a sky baby blue type of look and
the rails are even more pale blue but
they go together since they both sort of
feel like a desaturated in a way bonus
points if you wear a lot of blue jeans i
think this is this is giving me iphone
5c vibes i'm gonna go eight out of ten
then black you already know i got a soft
spot for matte black and this one is
right up that alley super clean
stealthy
dark mode all those things even the
bands kind of sort of look like batman's
art pieces only downside is this one is
definitely going to show the most
fingerprints so i'm going 8 out of 10
again then yellow this one
has like a taxi vibe to it i don't know
there's not a whole lot of yellow items
in my life but if they were i'm sure
this would be more saturated yellow than
all of them and this wouldn't be so bad
but the aluminum sides of this one are
really pale like almost different color
yellow it's kind of weird it just sort
of reminds me of the worst version of
the iphone 5c i wasn't into that not my
style sorry yellow four out of ten and
then last but not least product red
damn this is nice this is like a deep
rich ferrari red
and we're actually getting it on day one
instead of waiting six months and it has
that black front and the colored camera
ring looks good on pretty much all these
phones but i'd say looks the best here
and the aluminum frame matches i'd say
the most closely of any of the colors
aside from the white this one is a
winner easily my favorite color option
9.5 out of 10. but there you have it
that is iphone 10r it's like that it's a
funky frankenstein iphone with some
things from iphone 8 some things from
iphone 10 it kind of technically
qualifies in that way as a new design
and you can even kind of see some of the
color of the aluminum frame up on the
front so a wallpaper that matches it
does make a real difference basically
you can look at this phone as sort of
the new iphone 8. this is the ideal
upgrade for someone on an iphone 8 or
older right now
not an iphone 10. it's going to start at
749 for 64 gigs definitely not cheap but
still much cheaper than the iphone 10 s
and it's going to come out about a month
after the 10s in october so stay tuned
for the full review when i do get my
hands on these things but until the next
one thanks for watching r.i.p to the
home button catch you guys in the next
one
peace